now you were uh like the like if I'm not
mistaken the most prolific uh Myspace
uh what do you call it like uh Tom yeah
I mean you were like yeah
1.0 is like Myspace right yeah the first
place to go viral really was Myspace
right I mean how big of of uh
like Catalyst for your comedy was the
Myspace it was like okay so leading up
to
um Myspace was like I see this internet
thing happening I'm on things like AOL
instant messenger and I'm trying to
share my screen name I'm kind of seeing
like oh wow this is like I'm finding
people like somebody in South Dakota is
like I'm following you and I was like
that's kind of cool I don't think I'll
ever go there maybe I don't know if I'll
ever tour there and writing this person
I'm doing that for a couple years and
then Myspace hits and I'm like let me
put on a page and Link everybody on that
uh instant messenger which now you'd say
DM right and I'll put it all on there
and I kind of had a hub and invited
everybody on there within a couple of
weeks I had 2500 people now here's
what's funny the week the month before
I was in a rut I was super miserable I
literally called my mother I was like I
don't know why I'm even out here anymore
because everything I thought was going
on is not you know in L.A in L.A yeah a
couple of things that I thought were
like sparkly dulled and I had a couple
of little hits on TV but for the most
part except for doing College gigs
um Hollywood was not saying like you
you're up it was like no we already have
somebody kind of sort of like you
and I brought no data really I didn't
have a TV show nothing successful except
like I could show you receipts of Tour
tickets
so I'm like she my mom and I talk and
she's like
why don't you just keep doing that thing
where you're like you know conversating
with people that's kind of unique that's
kind of cool and I was like yeah this
new thing Myspace I get on there I take
my 2500 people and one night I come home
from the Laugh Factory and I spend the
whole night I think I probably respond
to 2500 people like welcome to video by
their name hey Carla in we're in Iowa I
sought your birthday last week happy
birthday here's a link and I start
sending people I spend the whole night a
link to it like some comedy MP3 comedy I
uploaded some excerpt right
a couple days later I'm dating this girl
Cassidy I remember Cassidy comes down
into the office and she hears me
laughing and she's like she comes down
she's like what's up and I was like
I go look at this I go it's 3 800 people
and like what are 12 hours and now these
new people like I just got your link and
I'm watching three weeks later it's
um six thousand or seven thousand
that same girlfriend she walks in and
she goes
keep in mind I was miserable what five
weeks before like
no clue what my path forward was and I'm
sitting with my arms behind my head I'm
just like sitting in my [__]
underwear with some fruit loops and I'm
just I'm looking at the computer she
goes what is going on in here I go
I'm about to take over the world
because you are and I was like I this
nobody realizes and I was telling people
I wasn't even keeping it like covert I
was going to the club do this right try
this out and those same Comics uh we're
gonna go party we're you know kind of
dismiss me I go home every night for
four years
I shook every hand digitally with every
fan and sent links to pretty much every
single person until I had millions of
followers and could not do it anymore
man and Madison Square Garden one click
two shows sold out one click I'm there
on this date
and after that Nothing Was the Same
again in my life how many people shows
up at Madison Square Garden two shows of
yeah a little 18 5 or something like
that in the round though is like full
like almost 20 000. it's got the vicious
circle that was the rough around yeah
Vicious Circle Vicious Circle was fast
and what were you doing before medicine
like how big a venue
before that like before that college
gigs like I kind of hit like a maybe 25
2800 so you went from 2800 200 2800 20
000 28 2820 maybe like a three or four
thousand ready then Penn State which I I
started filming everything for what was
then known as webisodes you know like
little Clips excerpts and so I was I
brought a camera crew and I filmed a one
month of touring with Bobby Kelly Gary
gallman Jay Davis and I filmed something
that I thought was just gonna be free
webisodes and ended up getting vicious
circle from HBO Chris albrech was it at
HBO offered me my first special he's
like what are you gonna do I go I'm
gonna do this tour and try to drum up
some more fans by the time I got to Penn
State
they called me up it was supposed to be
3 800 4 000 people they said we just
moved your show to the field house 12
000 people are here and I filmed it so I
have that night on film I go and I see
Chris Albrecht he goes what are you
gonna do now that you're done with the
tour I said I got 400 hours of footage
for [__] free episodes that I need to
edit and he goes pop one in I had him in
a duffel bag I throw it in
Chris albrech HBO he goes this is like a
show
yeah I go all right we didn't film like
a show we just filmed everything he goes
cut it up into Eight Episodes I'll buy
this right now we'll put this on call it
whatever you want to call it tourism
yeah and then it aired before Vicious
Circle did you do that with uh New Wave
slash comedy that's right well I was
with Barry Katz at the time and I think
he had folded into that company right
yeah yeah it was right around that time
I think they they joined forces because
I remember being at New Wave and seeing
that yeah it was right around that time
but I was already like honestly My
Philosophy was already so different from
a traditional business route that even
then I was
already looking and thinking like I
don't want to depend on I could do this
myself people they were asking me what
to do because I knew more about tech
probably similar to the way you are now
I'm asking you questions now going like
hey who do you use for your blah blah
it's like I was in the know when nobody
else really was it's called Stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole and if you go on
Amazon and type in Stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and Order yourself a
bottle you'd be really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of Amazon and if you buy a bottle
we might go up the ladder and that would
mean a lot so please get on Amazon and
buy Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude